this week on quadriga after the coup
Egypt on the brink dozens of people have
died as supporters at Mohamed Morsi and
the Muslim Brotherhood protest against
the overthrow of their democratically
elected president by the military he was
pushed out after just a year in office
huge numbers of Egyptians had turned out
in Tahrir Square demanding his
resignation they accused him of
authoritarianism and steering the
country towards an Islamist dictatorship
after days of protests the army stepped
in Morsi was arrested the army appointed
a new president and promised elections
in six months time positions have become
entrenched between those who oppose and
those who support the military coup does
morsi's overthrow mark a new start for
democracy or has paved the way for a
civil war your host this week Ali Osman
hello and welcome to quadriga former
President Mubarak ruled Egypt for three
decades before the Egyptian people in
the military showed him the door it took
his successor Mohamed Morsi only one
year to suffer the same fate so leaving
Egypt again in his in a very difficult
situation in a delicate situation where
everybody is wondering and asking where
is the country headed and that's exactly
what I will be asking my three gets all
we've been following events in Egypt
very closely welcome to vomit up there's
some odd who's a German Egyptian
political scientist and the author of
several best-selling books such as the
downfall of the Islamic world three
prominent Islamic shakes have recently
issued death threats against him
accusing him of insulting Islam and the
Prophet young cool man is a freelance
german journalist specializing in the
Middle East and the Arab world he has
reported for the GPA news agency and now
works for a variety of newspapers
magazines and radio stations and Tom
gallery was a seasoned journalist who in
the past has worked for the BBC the
German public broadcaster ard and the
Egyptian monthly Egypt today he now
works as a freelance journalist and
political
analyst of us and Middle Eastern affairs
welcome to you all gentlemen indeed very
delicate times in Egypt these days huh
made up delsym art and before we talk
about the current situation let's
backtrack a few days in a sense when the
military stepped in and a lot of people
inside and certainly outside Egypt are
still wandering in debating whether the
ouster of Mohamed Morsi amounted to a
military coup or was it just the
military merely executing the will of
the Egyptian people what's your take
well let me say it wasn't really a coup
because he wasn't really a president he
seemed to be just a marionette of the
Muslim Brotherhood's he was not making
his own decisions but carrying out the
agenda of the leaders of the Muslim
Brotherhood that was the core problem
and we should not forget that Mohammed
Morsi and the Muslim brothers made a
coup first against democracy against the
state of low tried to undermine the
institutions of the country tried to
Islamize everything in Egypt and they
were dragging the economy of the country
towards cows and therefore masses of
people took to the streets and the army
couldn't just watch everything without
doing thing if the army had to intervene
the Muslim Brotherhood were trying to
hijack Egypt and this action from my
point of view is just a trial to free
the hijacked Egypt and bring it back to
its people but at the same time we're
talking about a president who in june
till 2012 was elected with 51 percent of
the vote so the 51% whose vote if you
will whose voices have been robbed what
do you say to that there is a great
difference between legal and legitimate
and he was legally elected that's the
process of election but legitimacy is a
long term process he has to govern
according to the Democratic rules he
didn't he has to be a president of all
Egyptians as he vowed but he didn't and
he has to respect the institutions but
he didn't he allowed his supporters his
cheers to siege the Supreme Court
Supreme Constitutional Court to avoid a
judgment against him and against his
Constitution he allowed his malicious to
kill peaceful demonstrators in front of
the presidential palace early in
december last year and he lost the
legitimacy exactly by doing this
therefore we should always differentiate
between legally elected and legitimate
because democracy is not a Catholic
marriage where wife is not allowed to
divorce although the husband is
alcoholic and he's raping here every
night well yang Coleman democracy is not
a Catholic marriage ahamad up elsamma
but what would you say a lot of people
are saying and debating whether this was
a military intervention worth it versus
a popular intervention what's your take
it was clearly a military intervention
and I'm a kind of surprised that you
were praising the military so much
because I remember after Mubarak fell
down we also had the military step in
and you were much more critical at this
time of the military and what we clearly
can see now is that the military is
exactly doing what it did two years ago
so I'm a surprised that you you're
praising the military as so much but
anyway but anyway it's a military
intervention because we had free elected
president and just saying he doesn't
have why he didn't have legitimacy is
saying that the people didn't give give
him his foot boat he had the legitimacy
so he was the free elected president so
it was a clear military intervention
which does not mean that the the
military interval didn't have legitimacy
because there was so many people going
on the streets so many people just
wanted to get rid of Morsi so it's a
military intervention but it had
legitimacy that is for sure for me the
main problem is in the whole process I
mean we can talk for hours and days and
years about the question whether it was
a military coup or not for me the main
problem is that the main problem
Egyptian policy had in the past was that
you have such
deep it's a you have such deep that
you're not bringing together the both
sides this is the ridges parts on the
one hand and the non religious parties
on the other side so you have such a
deep rift between the two sides and
these rift now is even larger so I don't
see how you can bring the two sides
together and Egypt needs this if it's
really want to go towards democracy and
some gather indeed a lot of people are
saying the Egyptian society is even more
polarized today than it was a year ago a
lot of people are fearing that Egypt
might be headed into the direction of a
civil war you think those fears are
exaggerated yes I do and in those days I
feel even like being an Egyptian because
in my heart are both sides are beating
so to speak I couldn't disagree more
with what you have said before calling
the elections not legitimate and you
calling a coup d'etat which is a
creditor a military intervention well
how would you call it if the German army
bundeswehr would do the same here you
would call it a military intervention or
what we know why this is not called a
coup d'etat because the United States
the President of the United States rifai
refrained from calling it a coup d'état
and this has a reason because the label
coup would mean that then the US aid for
Egypt would have to be put on hot but
maybe the the United States and the
Western world you can think about what
this would mean for themselves not
calling what it is a break of law in
Egypt and they would betray their own
values if they would stick to your term
calling it just or downplaying it as a
military intervention to save what to
save democracy this is ridiculous
because i'm certainly not I'm well known
that I'm not a supporter of the Muslim
Brotherhood but I am a strong supporter
of democratic values and once you are
elected
the military has to stay out in every
country what would you say if mr.
Erdogan in Egypt in Turkey would have
the same fear also the Turkish army has
a history in include it as we do this
then call a justified military
intervention we have to be very very
careful about those downplaying
arguments and and stick to what we
experience now in Egypt we experienced a
massive problem about how to define
democracy and democracy is the will of
the majority of the people and the
majority of the Egyptian people voted or
elected Morsy as president a year ago
and this is not negotiable right so
let's pick up on what Hamid app does
somewhat earlier said though about the
legitimacy and the lost legitimacy of
the president of President Morsi do you
also think a lot of people said yes he
was elected with 51 51 percent of the
vote but then in November he issued a
decree granting himself extensive powers
and turning off a lot of people in the
process a lot of people point towards
that power grabbing move if you will as
a turning point in the perception of
Mohamed Morsi within Egypt what would
you say yes but on the other hand we
also had in December another river
referendum have a six months later or
from our perspective today six months
ago the Egyptian people again voted with
a huge majority for the new charter in
which you like it or not but in which
Islamic law for example was incorporated
and and so forth yes I understand that
there is a huge mass of Egyptians that
is upset or was upset about President
Morsi we have this tamarod charter 22
million
Egyptians signed for that Morsi should
step down maybe he lost in the past few
days before he was ousted the the
general view about how he is received by
by his own people however he was put
under such an enormous pressure that how
can how can you how can you make clear
decisions if the military sets you an
ultimatum pardon me where do we live
what kind of state is that this is
absolutely unacceptable by Western
standards I'm not talking about general
standards certainly not by Saudi
standards yes well Hamid up their
summits many Muslim brother leaders are
now in custody or in hiding and a lot of
supporters of the Muslim Brotherhood a
very angry and frustrated at what they
perceived to be the illegitimate rouster
of Mohammed Morsi what would you say to
these supporters who say listen a year
ago I went to the ballot box I went
through the Democratic means I cost my
vote for mom and Morsi he was elected
and now the president is gone due to a
military coup what would you say to a
muslim brotherhood supporter i will tell
them i understand your anger but I think
you got democracy wrong because
democracy doesn't mean that the majority
has the right to do everything and just
grab the power to itself you Muslim
brother had a chance to make a plural
Egypt to me to start a real democracy
and you missed your chance you got it
and you miss the chance now you have the
chance to come back and be a part of a
new government not determine everything
from above not Islamize the Constitution
and the society against the will of the
cops of winning women and the liberal
side in Egypt democracy means to
negotiate with different groups and to
get a compromise and they were not able
to to achieve a compromise because their
project is the state dicrotic a
theocracy state their project was not
democracy and plural
and I'm telling them if you are
threatening me today of a civil war then
you already lost every legitimacy you
have that it cannot be that the leaders
of the Muslim brothers are saying if
Morsi will not come back we will have
the algerian scenario will have the
syrian celerio and there will be car
bombs exploding everywhere what kind of
democracy is that that is showing that
they have been hijacking Egypt and they
cannot live with it now that there are a
lot of people are saying it sets a
dangerous precedent that the military
would and will step in every time if you
will a significant portion of the public
is displeased with politics we have that
in other countries as well and and he's
only been in power for a year and a lot
of people are saying we should have let
this thing run its course we should have
given him a chance for a few more years
to establish himself it's an exceptional
time an exceptional times need
exceptional procedures and measures and
Egypt democracy is still young and
fragile and need to be protected I'm the
last one to defend the army a coup
d'etat dear protects democracy you
cannot be serious saying this on air
look I mean this election had a clear
outcome and this is democracy you cannot
define democracy as you like it you have
to deal with results everywhere either
in Europe or in the Arab world and look
if this shall be an example for the Arab
world right so why why not let as you
said Ali let it run let it go and even
yes I see mistakes mr. Morsi did but why
not and give the people a chance to
confront him with the mistakes why to
intervene with military millions of
people more than those who elected him
went to the streets and protested
against him and we can talk about let me
let me finish my argument please we have
been talking about a country that didn't
reach the standards of democracy yet
which can enable us to set such
standards like
the army cannot intervene now we are now
sitting the ground for democracy and the
Muslim brother were the first who turned
against all the rules of democracy we
cannot wait three more years if you are
a sick person and you made a contract
with a doctor and after one year you
notice that your health is deteriorating
more you cannot say i will wait three
more years you might die and egypt was
dying egypt was bleeding out and the
people were intervening and the army had
no other choice it was not the plan of
the army the army was forced by the will
of the people to intervene and yes now
if we want to set real standards then we
have to roll back and start by the
constitution that the Muslim brother
were manipulating we need a strong
institution that gives power to the
institutions of the country not to
persons not to the president or prime
minister and that is the thing that will
prevent the next government to turn
against muckalee and prevent the army to
intervene again while the next
government has big problems on its hands
problems that the Muslim Brotherhood
Morsi in particular did not tackle and
many people blame him for it many people
are still saying poverty corruption and
unemployment social problems run rampant
in Egyptian society do you think was a
mistake on the part of Morsi not to
tackle those first and foremost problems
well one thing is for sure that really
if you look what went wrong in the last
year since he came to power it was
mainly the his fault or the fault of his
his partying of the Muslim Brotherhood
that he actually figured there's no
discussion about it and he was in power
so he is responsible for what happened
and but still I must say it's it's
really black and white if you just blame
only the Muslim Brotherhood for for
everything which went wrong in Egypt in
the last 12 months or even longer
because I mean the situation is not so
black and white it's much more complex
and if you can see that there are a lot
of forces within Egypt who were really
working against democracy the old guard
is what
the constitutional core which which got
rid of the freely elected parliament you
can see now like a one just in a few
days all of a sudden oil and gas are
back in Egypt and all the problems the
police is back on the streets Security's
back on the streets so you can really
clearly see that there were a lot of
people who try to boycott the whole
process towards democracy and even I
must say also the the opposition parties
they didn't play a very good role in the
whole situation they didn't have a clear
program yellow not they want they
weren't unified they didn't manage to
build up any kind of structures and one
thing is for sure I mean if you have
elections if they are really going to be
elections and I'm soon I'm really
doubted I'm completely with you I don't
see the military leading the country
towards democracy and for me if I didn't
say it clearly it was a cool as well I
just said it had some kind of legitimacy
from the people and if there are
elections i'm pretty sure that it won't
be the oppositional parties who benefit
from it but the Muslim Brotherhood still
will be strong the old guard probably
will be much stronger than it was in the
past and I think and one of the big
winners in the whole situation right now
other Salafis I mean look at the haze
benoa the Salafi party they're doing a
very very smart job and they will be I
mean in the last elections they have
already got something like twenty five
percent of the votes even more there
will be much more stronger I don't see
how the military which definitely is not
interested in democracy will lead the
country to democracy they are repeating
all what they did after mubarak was
ousted you have violation against human
rights 50 people were killed and it's
clear indication that it was the
military who killed them even if there
was a provocation I mean it's no reason
to kill 50 people unarmed and I don't
see Egypt moving to a Amakhosi right now
the military says young woman is not
interested in a real democracy in Egypt
and they've played a pivotal role ever
since nineteen fifty two
they've certainly played a pivotal role
this time around through the ouster and
with the ouster of President Mohammed
Morsi so time to take a look at the role
of the military in Egypt Egypt's
military has long had the country firmly
in its hands dictator Hosni Mubarak was
just one of a series of army officers to
rule as president in 2011 it was the
Armed Forces who helped push him out
after huge protests in Tahrir Square
army rules soon became unpopular in June
2012 mohamed morsi beat the army's
candidate to become president
a year later it was again the army who
stepped in to push him out and again
they were celebrated as liberators by
the crowds in Tahrir even when not
holding political office the Army has
always wielded massive power it's the
Armed Forces who received the bulk of
American aid over a billion dollars a
year and huge Suede's the economy are
under the Army's control everything from
manufacturing food to parts of the
tourist industry
well Tom gather spherically that the
military plays a very important
significant role in Egyptian politics
they have huge economic interests align
with in the country that they have if
you will consolidate it over the decades
and of course the 1.5 billion US every
year tolerate that they receive which
now is being called into question by a
lot of lawmakers in the United States in
particular US Senator John McCain is
saying perhaps it's time to rethink this
aid that we're giving on an annual basis
to the Egyptian military what would you
say yes I yes I couldn't agree more edit
it's not only him it's also within the
Democratic Party that we have a mind
change didn't Barack Obama always call
for a change yes it's time for a
significant change in u.s. politics in
Middle Eastern affairs and not to
constantly I ran into traps old traps
from old times when for example all the
United States permanently supported of
those regimes and old Mubarak so to
speak because they they thought and they
sold it as he he is a an ally to the
west and we now learned that if you
support those guys and those who seems
the people think you side with their
despots and the West cannot afford any
longer to send signals to Egypt or other
countries in the region that we signed
with the wrong guys but we need strong
signals that we signed with those who
stand up for democracy for freedom for
liberty of speech for equal T of women
and certainly the Muslim Brotherhood
neither and norther the Salafist and for
that however we need to give this region
time to learn what we did democracy
isn't this point I'm with you coming
back to the United States yes there
there is a change a shift of opinion too
wait and maybe this is what I hope
support support those forces in Egypt
who can actually lead to a democratic
system and this is definitely to bring
the military back into the garrisons
this is absolutely necessary and the
people need to decide what they want and
if they decide in a way the West doesn't
like so what the heck that's there well
they're free well and after somewhat the
military seem to have learned some
lessons at least from the ouster of
President Mubarak back then they were
themselves themselves they they took on
the power this time around they said
we're only supervising the transitional
period general LTZ made it clear that
he's not interested in running the
country rather he installed an interim
president chief justice Mansour do you
think that's a wise move it has to come
that way because they have seen in this
one year they took power they were
confronted with the Egyptian people for
the first time they are not trained to
deal with demonstrations so they were
shooting and were killing people and
this was of course harming their image
among Egyptians and the Egyptian people
have a very emotional relation to the
army and they want the army to do the
job it's a sign for to protect the
borders and take care of the security of
the people not to govern and yet when
they are going back to the background
they still want to have the control
because they have the power and let's
face it this is the fact it's the only
institution in Egypt that really works
right now every other institutions are
damaged and are not disciplined even the
Muslim brother they were having this
legend that they are the best organized
force in Egypt this proved to be fake
they are not really good organized and
they couldn't run the country now the
army wants to step back control the
things from the background and I think
it doesn't matter for the army if we
will have a democracy or a dictatorship
all
what the army needs is security that the
investors will come back that the
tourists will come back that what the
Muslim brother didn't do anything to do
that therefore it's easier for the
Democratic parties to cooperate with the
army now and find a common ground give
the army the same privileges and at the
course of time start to think about
taking these powers away third one did
it like this in Turkey but after he made
a economic change in the country then he
was having a popular support that
enabled him to cut off the privileges of
the party Mohammed Morsi wanted to
repeat what earth one did in 12 years in
only 12 months therefore he failed well
it's going to take a bit longer to
marginalize the Egyptian military from
Egyptian politics it seems but the army
also has shown somewhat heavy-handed
approach ever since this aastra of Morsi
more than 50 people just have been
killed recently Muslim Brotherhood
supporters many people are irritated
about this particular move even though
the facts differ depending on whom you
ask but do you think that the image of
the military has been damaged yes I mean
we don't know the whole story yet we we
have seen different videos it depends
who took the videos and all what I know
is that the leaders of the Muslim
brother at that day said that they are
gonna escalate tonight and they will
take extraordinary procedures to free
their president from the house of the
Republican Guards and at the same night
it came to that bloodshed and I'm asking
myself who profits the most from that
bloodshed who is staging this bloodshed
the army was shooting there is a fact
but who started shooting who was
provoking who should first and it's not
only pro-morsi demonstrators who died
also army officers were injured and
killed in this and this is taking us
the Syrian scenario the Muslim
Brotherhood in Syria were always saying
our hope is the brutality of the regime
our hope in the brutality of their gym
and therefore they were also accused of
killing civilians and saying it was the
regime of asset and I think the Muslim
brothers also they can do that I trust
the army to shoot at civilians they did
it before but I trust the Muslim
brothers to make this conspiracy to show
the army in front of the world and in
front of the Egyptian people as
illegitimate they are profiting the most
from that therefore they carry also at
least fifty percent of their
responsibility about what happened in
front of 50 on our people that's really
I'm artists for me I I have I have no
idea how this can come I will tell you
tell me whether you get this information
that those people will not be argued I
will tell you and for me I don't bring
this together with any kind of road to
democracy really this is asad like
behavior but just killing people and
even if there had been some kind of
provocation and I'm pretty sure there
was a kind of provocation I mean there
are kinds of de-escalation and I don't
see that you really have to kill 50
people if you don't want to and it was a
clear warning shot towards the Muslim
Brotherhood this was the motive of the
military and if you really read
carefully what journalists have
collected from eyewitnesses who were at
this place even eyewitnesses who were
against Morsi even they say that it was
the military who escalated the whole
conflict I mean Wall Street just read
the New York Times which really was
praised even by by mossy opponents for
his coverage of the whole story I mean
you can read clearly and they're clear
indications that it was to start the
army who escalated this and its really
interesting how you are downplaying this
I just it's just sounds I'm just saying
we don't have the sack and I just said
both where what both were armed and most
were armed both were armed and we saw
the video that also they were shooting
from this side
I went to the Egyptian army and I was a
soldier in the Egyptian army and there
is a low in Egypt you don't get closer
to a military base and if you get closer
to a military base you are worn once
then the rush that did soldier is
shooting one in the air if you don't get
back it's a little more work Kira know
it is along the route of brother Ariel
there is saying that the military was
allowed to kill 50 people that's not for
me this is really not if there are no
I'm not just find that and those who
killed those who killed should be
brought to justice I'm just saying who
wanted this provocation the Muslim
brother exactly wanted that and they
said it hours before we are gonna storm
the house of the Republican Guards to
free our president and they are not
gonna storm that with was knives but
they were coming with guns and they were
shooting at the military and the
military was shooting back and
exaggerated that's the truth but you are
saying they were shooting at unarmed
people and this is not true all of a
sudden you have a very clear vision of
what happened I wonder what kind of
sources you have please just read all
the students but you're saying only the
US and even even the most opponents
there many mossy opponents who just say
it was the army who let it escalate I
mean they're they're much they've gone
much further than you have can escalate
in Sinai and mania and Alexandria who is
sending the militias on the street to
shoot at people you know how many people
were killed in CIA and amenia and
Alexandria and all other provinces of
Egypt what did the army too I think one
thing is for sure unfortunately we will
not be able to solve this case on this
very show but one thing that is for
certain is that in the immediate
aftermath of these killings as a
reaction the Salafists party has
withdrew from the interim talks as the
Muslim Brotherhood have said that those
talks are legit legitimate to begin with
do you see this this talk this
transitional period already unraveling
and I'm afraid it is so it is so I mean
just you just have to look at the time
table just within four weeks there
should be a new constitution with the
and there are 10 people no one knows
who's going to choose them six judges
which is a clear hint that they are from
the old guard so ten people which are
not democrat lead not not elected by
Democratic votes are going to give Egypt
a new constitution in four weeks I mean
look at Tunisia there's been discussing
for two years about the new constitution
right now it takes time it's not a job
you can do in in four weeks and and it's
not a job you can do in half a year so
it takes time it really it needs a
democratic basis it needs an election
basis otherwise it's there's no way for
me to have really a democratic state so
I'm gonna according to the time light
set forth by interim president Mansour
the parliamentary elections are supposed
to be held early 2014 and the
presidential elections ought to behold
immediately after the Parliament
convenes do you find this to be a
realistic timetable it would be if it is
if it wouldn't be just an announcement
in this respect we have to wait and see
but what for me is very important for
the future of Egypt and how we can
establish democracy there is to deal
with the poor because this is where
actually the Muslim Brotherhood failed
also not only to reach out to the
intellectuals but there are suburbs of
Cairo burn on of us would like to live
people live there like in caves whoever
was there sees they live within garbage
to the streets are filled covered by
garbage the houses look like caves and
more than 6 million of the 20 million
people in in Cairo live like that in
inhumane situations and the Muslim
Brotherhood was the first let me say
structured organization that tried at
least after the Revolution what is the
revolution for if not for improving
the standards of living for the poor
right like in the French Revolution but
they couldn't achieve anything to reach
out to the poor because they were also
put under a lot of pressure from other
groups to do this and that and so forth
coming back to my point whoever wants to
gain power and rule the country in a
decent way needs urgently to take care
of those poor if this doesn't work if we
if another regime will be elected or
kind of elected or installed or whatever
and again reaches out for big money of
the IMF and there is the u.s. also a lot
to blame and the the European Union who
always looked only for big money big
investment and again when I now see a
coming in and that Egypt is showered by
golf money oh my god this is the wrong
direction we need programs that reach
out for the poor and this will lead to
yes L and an economy in Egypt that is
not as fast Lee growing as the military
would like to see right the military is
interested in big money but we need to
win we need means the people needs to
win or if the new government needs to
win the hearts and minds of the poor and
you're referring to the five billion
dollars in grants and loans that have
been promised by Qatar and Saudi Arabia
to be pledged both countries who have
supported by the way the move on the
part of the military let's look at the
transitional period one once more Hamid
up there some odd cabinets posts have
been offered to the Muslim Brotherhood
and the seller fees but the Muslim
Brotherhood has already said that
they're going to reject them roadmap no
matter what do you think that it's
Egypt's in the future is viable the part
is viable if the Muslim Brotherhood are
excluded they are not excluded they have
exclude themselves they don't want to be
a part of a solution because they want
to determine the solution
have been robbed they're saying they're
well that's history they can go and do
whatever they want now we have new
reality and we got the reset button and
we got back to 2011 as mubarak was
dropped so when we are starting
everything and you and they have chosen
this way not to be a part of it I think
it's even more constructive that they
are not a part of a government now
because they have been always a troyian
horse if they enter any government they
are gonna this make make it in stable
from inside because they never learn to
cooperate with others they have been
living in underground all their history
talking only to each other like in a
dark cave and now they cannot cooperate
with people who have other ideological
background what we need now is a
technocratic government I agree with you
that who should start working for the
economy and for the poor people and try
to show the young Egyptians light at the
end of the tunnel that is what the
Muslim brother missed to do because they
were busy trying to empower themselves
instead of cooperating with the
institution they always stood for
actually and this is what make them make
them and makes them opponents of the
oil-rich neighbors of Egypt and this is
why actually Saudi Arabia supports the
the military coup in Egypt because it
feared the success of the Muslim
Brotherhood and its reach out to the
poor because this would also put an end
to the other other desperate assessment
systems on the peninsula Saudi Peninsula
and we need to understand that the
Muslim Brotherhood didn't really
actually get a fair chance to do that
job they actually wanted to do because
they they were also forest to be busy
with a lot of lawmaking etcetera this is
how it works if you establish a new
democracy yes but there was a point that
we are getting wrong here we were
thinking that the Muslim brother were
doing a lot of things for the poor I
think they were just managing poverty
they didn't they did nothing to change
the facts of poverty in Egypt we
cause they had let me let me just finish
let me finish ladies a lot now let me
finish my point because they didn't
change their strategy of begging so that
the whole economical cups concept of the
Muslim brother was begging money from
abroad and let the Egyptian people beg
this money from them they didn't help
the poor to help themselves they always
wanted to have the poor depending on
them therefore they were giving them
especially short time before the
election and Saudi Arabia didn't
intervene because it's fearing that the
Muslim brother will do something for the
poor Saudi Arabia is fearing the him
that the power of the Muslim brother in
the regional power and Saudi Arabia was
opposing master because of that and now
it's opposing the Muslim Brotherhood
they missed the chance to do real
economy and therefore they are also
famous the chances after summit young
cumin what is your prediction for the
next weeks and months to come in Egypt
I'm not very optimistic about the next
weeks and months I think on the long run
still Egypt will hopefully find its way
to democracy but in the short run I'm
rather pessimistic and and one thing is
for sure if you want to have really
something going towards democracy the
Muslim Brotherhood has to be involved
you just you just need them there's a
strong force they are also capable of
developing more towards democracy until
now they have only develop kind of
formal understanding of democracy I
think if there's a new generation coming
they're good chances that they're going
to develop it's not for sure that this
is going to happen no one knows but at
least there's a chance but one thing's
for sure you need the Muslim Brotherhood
they're so strong something like no one
can say exactly but let's say about a
quarter of the population probably is
still pro-morsi perhaps a bit more
perhaps a bit less but you need them and
you have to involve them in the
political process if you don't do this
if you're not interested in it winded if
you're saying you have to buy line then
then you are definitely not interested
in democracy this is for sure do you
expect more bloodshed more violence
along the way
I'm afraid so yeah I'm afraid so I hope
that there are some wise men within the
Muslim Brotherhood we say okay we lost
and we have to give it a second try in
the interest of the country I'm not sure
if they are able to do that your take I
think the Muslim Brotherhood's chance is
right now what they have missed before
this is now because they can gain even
the hearts and minds of the West who are
many in the West sympathize with them
because we in the West think they have
been ousted unfairly and not by
Democratic standards and therefore
actually I I'm optimistic for Egypt no
matter how many victims we will have in
the near future but I think Egypt is on
the right track Egypt is on the right
track says tom gola well if this heated
debate today was any indication at all
as to how great the divide these days is
in Egypt then you know what obstacles
and challenges lie ahead for that
country we will of course continue to
monitor the situation in Egypt so I want
to thank you out there for tuning in I
want to take my guests for this very
spirited and sometimes heated discussion
and I look forward to seeing you again
at some point over the next few weeks
and I look forward to seeing you again
next week for a new edition of quadriga
thanks for watching
you